bien esta vez vamos a hacer casas si
este casitas así con palillos como
palillos de dientes y lo que quiero
saber es cuántos palillos necesito para
hacer casas casitas a ver vamos a
empezar en la primer casita que voy a
hacer es esta
esta será la casa número 1 y para hacer
las cosas más ordenadas quiero hacer una
tabla para ir llevando el conteo de todo
lo que voy haciendo entonces a ver
déjame poner aquí el número de casas
de casas y de este lado voy a poner el
número de palillos
muy bien entonces para la casa número 1
que es la que tenemos aquí
usamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 palillos bueno
vamos a hacer la siguiente y la idea es
que sean casas contiguas
es como un condominio un condominio
horizontal entonces vamos a compartir la
pared derecha y ahora vamos a poner la
siguiente casa contigua a la primera
entonces la casa número 2 y compartimos
este muro que está entre las dos y
entonces ahora necesite 1 2 3 4 5 o sea
que para la casa número 2
tuve que adicionar 5
5 palillos aquí tuve que adicionar 5 y
ahora tengo 11
vamos con la tercera casa en la tercer
casa pues otra vez es contigo es el
mismo condominio y un poco se empieza a
ver el patrón de lo que está ocurriendo
entonces la casa número 3 necesitaré
agregar 5 palillos que es lo que está
aquí entonces agregó 5 palillos para la
casa número 3 y ahora tengo 16 en total
vámonos con la 4 de una vez esto ya ya
vimos por donde va
entonces la 4 pues será muy similar
y otra vez tuve que agregar 5 palillos
para la casa número 4 entonces la casa
número 4 me tomo 5 palillos más y ahora
llevo en total 21
lo que yo quisiera hacer es encontrar un
modelo que me permitiera calcular
cuántos palillos necesito digamos para
la casa número 50 o las 300 o la 4000
voy a acomodar tantito
mi espacio si para que me dé
este
y lo acomodó vamos a empezar a proponer
un modelo que nos sirva para entender y
poder saber cuántos palillos voy a
necesitar para cualquier número de casas
analizando observamos que el 6 es común
a todas entonces empecemos por la casa
número 4 y podríamos decir que la casa
número 4 para saber el número de palitos
para llegar hasta 4 casas está el 6
inicial que corresponde a la casa número
1 + 5 veces las tres casas adicionales
que hice sí o sea la 2 la 3 y la 4
observamos que cuando tengo 3 casas o
sea los 16 palillos yo podría escribirlo
como el 6 inicial más
cinco veces el número de casas
adicionales a la primera que tengo que
son dos para el caso de las dos casas
tenemos una situación muy similar con
seis palillos de la primera casa más
cinco veces el número de casas
adicionales a la primera que en este
caso es uno y para la primera casa
podríamos decir que tenemos los seis
palillos iniciales pero me gustaría de
una vez seguir con este planteamiento
que estamos haciendo y podría pensar en
cuántas veces cinco palillos le agregué
a pues puedo pensar que le agregué cero
veces cinco palillos y esto ya empieza a
tomar una forma de un modelo y quisiera
ahora describirlo de esta manera
pensemos que este número que está
multiplicando al 5 es el número de casas
menos 1 cabe déjame escribirlo para que
sea más claro
o sea yo podría pensar que este es igual
al 6
+ 5 veces
4 - 1
pues sí porque 4 - 1 estrés y este de
aquí será 6 5
x 3 - 1 y este que está aquí será seis
más cinco veces dos menos uno y este que
está aquí es seis más cinco veces uno
menos uno ahora esto ya tomó una buena
forma porque este cuatro a ver vamos a
indicarlo este 4 que está aquí es el
mismo del número de casas o sea este 4
es este luego el 3 déjame ver qué color
claro este 3 de la tercera casa es el
que está aquí muy bien luego tenemos al
2 de la segunda casa que está aquí y
luego tenemos al 1 que es el mismo que
está aquí de la primer casa entonces
ahora ya encontramos un modelo con el
cual por ejemplo podríamos saber cuántos
palillos voy a necesitar para la casa
número 50 a veces vamos a hacerlo en
naranja entonces este es número sigue
creciendo el número de casas y llegamos
al 50 y ahora ya podemos saber cuántos
palillos vamos a necesitar porque el
número de palillos será igual
a 6
+ 5 veces
el número de casas que 50 -1 y esto es
igual a 6
más cinco veces por 49
5 veces 49 es igual a 245
y esto será igual a 6 245 y entonces
necesito 251 palillos